Hey guys, hows it going its Justine This is my sister Jenna, Hello!
I'm going to link in the description to her channel, what? happy birthday. Oh
Thank you. Happy birthday to you! happy birthday to you!
You today is my Birthday!!!!!!!
So today's my birthday to celebrate I'm going to be number one making a cake and number two the most important part about this video
Is I set up a donation link for charity water?
I'm working with charity water for so long you guys have donated in the past too many wells that we've built and I'm so excited
Because today for my birthday, we're going to build some wells and so this cake that I'm going to be doing yeah
What are you you haven't told me a plan and I'm scared
We're going to make this into a cake, and then we're going to put a cup in the middle and put water in it
Okay, yeah, and make sense. It makes sense in my mind. Yeah, It makes sense. So in addition to whatever you guys donate
I'm going to match Donations up to five thousand dollars. So as soon as we hit  five thousand dollars, then I'm donating 5 thousand dollars
Well, I mean, I'd like to get 20,000 about the pretty high goals. Yeah, shoot for the stars
All of the info is in the description and if you guys can donate a dollar or fifty cents
Whatever anything will help and you guys can leave me like little messages in the little description and just know that we are helping
Change people's lives which is super exciting now. We got to make the cake to go with it
Funfetti the most
important part of
Baking would you like to spray the pan?
[too] much
No, it's okay. She gets a sign through. No yes, okay good
You didn't put enough oh, God
I'm gonna let you do it. I'm doing it going. Don't touch. Cause usually  I'm like ah I'm like AH its stuck
oh Because i was in charge of the spray
Look at this fancy egg carton, This is the best thing I have ever got. wow I rip off the things so
I know if they're expired. I just throw it in there. Oh
march 23rd. They're so good. [wow] you want me to get you one to know I'm okay
So cool. Look guys it does look nice. No periods 130 bucks
It's for your close-up shot. Oh, no
Get me a water bottle
I'm going to comment on it
one half cup Spoil
Oh my gosh, Look how close this is. I almost knocked us off
Because water is actually not really even blue, but water is portrayed as being blue
Let's do this the teal in the movie that is extremely concentrated
Yeah, hopefully.. HOLYMOLY!!! I've been making for a very long time at
My [sea] [foam]. It's actually quite good really
Having it for my [birthday]. We're going to need I'm on it. Yep
Instead of a bunch pan 39 to 43 minutes wow that's my bedtime. What is not very high on a bow tie
Up 70
You need one. We do grow map Rele'w devices income hey Alexa no wait. Oh cousin
Alexa penet timer for Thirty nine minutes, okay, we're gonna do it [oh]
Baby are taking
Its out its out of it. Let's take a look at it. Oh mommy. Oh wow
Disregard that. Oh my goodness. I'm screwed
Haha, would you really happened?
Second tree. Oh no
Mos, Espa toodles do you believe I was going to do that? Oh?
boy, oh
Wow, oh, shoot nothing
It's done, but like they're not done. This is no, it's not gone p. What that many other there who else'll even though
This seems like only to work
Give me bear no, but I am yeah what the hell in it because I'm so not our cake. That's not
Flat, huh?
I'm just going to try to even this up just a little sheriff knows the mutt fam
Yeah, we don't need that anymore you lobby for you. That's what I like. That's what I like. Oh, man. I made a mistake. Oh
no see some
English hurry up, and I said yeah, maybe okay
ready
You just want to do it. I don't mess it up
Oh, maybe cuz I'm not very yeah, I can do it is over here, okay?
Ok John. Don't
Yeah, so now we're going to put our water cup in hey
Take an indefinite the blue cake oh, I see sprinkles
Mm-Hmm. We're back at it skin a lot
It doesn't like a big doughnut
all right, I
Think it's beautiful. What's good look at this I?
Don't give you a goldfish in there can we got a goldfish tomorrow no?
No, it's a little better than we have another pet Jenna might be like Jenna. I'm out of town [so] much
Oh my God. I run by fish and my god over well. Thank you guys for watching here
We have enjoyed this video
But most importantly please please please check out the link that I have in the description to my charity water well
I'm hoping to reach a goal of 1,000 so we'll see what we can do we also made some cupcakes of Rowan, Jenna Channel
So go check out that video as well, and if you wanna see us taste-test this i'll be posting that in my vlog tomorrow
So check that out. I'll see you later
Thanks For Watching! :)